fröhlich sauer und zack wieder gut drauf
alles auf knopfdruck so stellt sich ein
hersteller von neuartigen sexpuppen in
china die ideale gefährtin für den
einsamen mann vor eine puppe für alle
lebenslagen mit gefühlen und
sprachfunktionen sogar schmollen kann
sie so de oder baby soll aber nicht wie
man auf den ersten blick annehmen könnte
nur für die sexuellen gelüste ihrer
menschlichen partner zur verfügung
stehen
es gibt einige kunden die zum beispiel
den tag an dem sie ihre puppe bekommen
als geburtstag feiern
sie geben ihre puppe einen namen und
fand diesen tag dann jedes jahr
sie backen kuchen und trinken ein
gläschen wein
eines tages sollen die puppen
ausgestattet mit künstlicher intelligenz
babysitter oder altenpfleger ersetzen
und im haushalt helfen denn sex ist ja
bekanntlich nicht alles
[Musik]